macron donc continue sa tournée pour
tenter de désamorcer la crise autour de
l'ukraine après moscou hier le président
français et à kiev aujourd'hui où il
doit s'entretenir dans les heures qui
viennent avec le président hélène ski
alors que peut-on attendre de cette
rencontre on retrouve tout de suite
notre envoyé spécial à kiev james andrei
les ukrainiens qu'on a pu rencontrer
nous expliquent qu'ils sont évidemment
très content et qu'il y ait une
initiative diplomatique de cette
envergure que le président français se
déplace effectivement jusqu'à moscou
pour tenter de négocier une solution
dans le même temps beaucoup disent ici
aussi qu'ils auraient préféré voir
emmanuel macron passé par kiev d'abord
avant de se rendre en russie évidemment
la diplomatie française a fait le choix
inverse comme on a pu le voir espérant
arriver avec des propositions à mettre
sur la table aujourd'hui justement avec
le président céline ce qu'il faut savoir
également que l'ambiance et on va dire
particulière ici à kiev c'est à dire
qu'à la fois la vie apparaît très normal
et les gens vaquent à leurs occupations
mais que dans le même temps lorsque vous
regardez un journal télévisé ou vous
ouvrez un journal papier et bien les
articles vont vous parler par exemple
des scénarios possibles d'invasion ou
encore j'ai lu ça ce matin dans un
journal local de la manière dont il
fallait s'y prendre pour pouvoir fuir le
pays en voiture le cas échéant et quels
papiers il fallait emporter avec soi
faut se souvenir que les ventes d'armes
ici en ukraine ont explosé et
qu'également il y à un grand nombre de
formations qui sont dispensés à la
population pour pouvoir défendre le pays
en cas d'invasion donc une ambiance on
va dire entre deux avec un véritable une
véritable tension malgré tout dans les
têtes tout le monde en parle et il ya ce
qu'on appelle ici l'invasion nos maîtres
dans les gens discutent lorsqu'ils se
rencontrent mais a malgré tout la vie à
peu près normale à kiev